we have even more 2020 Democratic
candidates to talk about the field is
getting very very full senator Cory
Booker is now running running South Bend
Indiana mayor Pete Budaj is running we
already had Julian Castro and John
Delaney and Tulsi Gabbard Kirsten
Gillibrand Kamala Harris Elizabeth
Warren Andrew yang even pseudo-science
Wu lady who I've interviewed before
marianne williamson is running even
though she obviously has no shot Richard
Oh Jetta was running although he has
already ended his campaign after not
getting any traction I am now ready to
eliminate a couple of people from the
candidates I will consider a reminder I
already told you last week I am NOT
supporting Kamala Harris Kamala Harris
softened instantly on the issue of
Medicare for all I know that there are
people in the audience who are more
concerned about Kamala Harris's a
criminal justice record as Attorney
General of California that is concerning
but she did this insta flip on Medicare
for all
after last week's Town Hall and as I
mentioned last week she's negotiating
against herself and random conservatives
who slammed her for saying she's all in
on Medicare for all period her staff
ended up putting out a statement saying
well she wants Medicare for all she's
open to all options so she's doing
exactly what I predicted many candidates
would ultimately do which is pay lip
service to Medicare for all but
ultimately back off of it remember the
Democratic Party platform is not
Medicare for all it's expanding the
Medicare opt-in down to 55 and having a
public option as part of the for-profit
health care system so Kamla herecome all
harris's out as far as I'm concerned
Tulsi Gabbard was all but crossed off my
list when she announced and I did a long
piece about it her foreign policy views
are concerning whole litany of issues
with Tulsi Gabbard but now I'm ready to
cross her off of my list list as well
her entire video explaining her
awakening on LGBT issues just did not
ring particularly genuine to me but what
actually pushed me over the edge with
Tulsi
a bird is that I'm just sick of her
posturing on war and military action
I've been looking in more detail at all
of her statements and positions and her
foreign policy strikes me as just a sort
of pretzel of broken logic I don't know
if that a metaphor makes sense but her
foreign policy doesn't really make sense
to me on the one hand she pitches
herself as anti-war she's against
interventionist regimes okay that's a
good start in many senses but then the
problem is that she calls herself a hawk
when it comes to counterterrorism
including using drones and deployment of
special ops and countries that aren't
even at war with the United States which
to me is a way to play coy with being
anti-war while actually favoring a ton
of hawkish policy that I'm against but
then at the same time to sort of flip
flip and flip again on this issue she is
sometimes totally anti interventionist
to a fault
like for example defending Syrian
dictator Bashar al-assad as merely a
victim of American aggression and
bullying and someone who should just be
left alone she's actually even defended
the Russian policy of bombing people to
help Bashar al-assad she wants the
United States staying out where we don't
belong but she has this relationship
with and supporter supports Indian Prime
Minister Modi Israeli Prime Minister
Netanyahu both of whom are just
hard-hard right on foreign policy
so I find tulsi gabbard to be a fraud on
foreign policy I have no real interest
in even continuing to criticize her
she's just not in the running for my
support at this point in time and I want
to be super clear on this it's not just
one position of hers it's the totality
of her actions and positions versus her
rhetoric and self framing of what her
views are it's just not for me
and I know that every time I talk about
this much like Venezuela I get some
angry emails from people who say David
you're just way off check out this or
that commentator they know the truth
about Tulsi Gabbard and we should all be
supporting her she's the only candidate
that we should even be considered
on the left or Democrat it's not for me
okay it's just it's not my thing I've
told you why you can disagree with me
but I'm being completely transparent
about why I won't be supporting Tulsi
Gabbard a cory booker i am skeptical of
as as I've said before but I am still
investigating his broader views so for
me right now Elizabeth Warren is near
the top of my list
Andrew yang is near the top of my list
and I'm waiting to see who else gets
involved will Bernie run we still don't
know but Harris and Gabbard are pretty
close to the bottom of my list I'd love
to hear from you where are you on the
2020 Democratic primary only on the
basis of the candidates that have
actually announced that they're running
let me know i'm on instagram at david
pakman follow me there follow the show
on instagram at david pakman show